hello everyone and welcome to another
game from the penultimate round of the
norway chess 2022 it's magnus cross and
with the white pieces against maxine
vashilagrav and again we will have
another clash between the two of them uh
in the groomfelder defense which is
always a pleasure maxine being the uh
well the greatest groomfield expert in
the world and he always plays very
enjoyable games and magnus just a very
strong player uh all together so let's
dive straight into it as there is quite
a lot to enjoy you will have one very
very difficult positive video moment but
i think it's also going to be a nice one
for you
so magnus has the white pieces and he
opens with d4 which pretty much against
maxim knows that we will have a
groomfield so knight to f6 c for g6
knights to c3 and d5 the groomfield
defense is on the board we have c
characters knight captures and e4 going
for the uh center grab the exchange
variation is here knight captures b
captures and bishop to g7 and now again
there are
many possible uh ways to continue the
game for white we always mention this
knight to f3 uh bishop to c4 basically
the most popular the knight f3 bishop to
e3 but a magnus plays bishop to b5 with
chuck he says
all right let's play the fourth most
popular continuation just to see if you
really know your stuff
so here is c6
blocking check with bishop to a4 and now
b5 uh maxim says thank you for this free
queen side expansion uh bishop to b3 and
now pawn all the way to a5 we have
knight to f3 by magnus and both players
castle so castles castles and now
there are a couple of uh games that
reach this position for example in the
game nakamura versus yanni palmishin the
grand chester blitz in paris c5 was
played and their game ended in a draw
but here we have a4 by maxine and a4 is
indeed the engine's top recommendation
so maksim obviously knows about that
game and he knows he's not he's
groomfield uh and it is now as of movie
11 that we have a completely new game so
magnus brings the bishop back bishop to
c2 and now uh challenging the center
with c5 makes sense the rook is still on
a1 so we want to strike at the center as
soon as possible so rook to b1 by magnus
and now bishop to g4 and uh now okay the
pawn is attacked but when has maxim ever
defended upon and you can't really just
go palm grabbing here if play rook
captures on b5 then c captures on d4 the
knight is uh not really defending there
and it captures knight to c6 we just add
another attacker and you're you're now
already playing maxim's game and it's
not really an and not a fun thing to do
if you advance the pawn the knight d4
the knight now uh cannot really be
defended well uh so you have to play
something else and it's just not not
only all the great rookie d5 for example
attacks the queen queen b6 and so on but
uh
most likely you are playing exactly what
maxine wants you to play so a magnus
plays e5 this limits the
power of the of the dark square bishop
here and knight to c6 we just continue
uh uh
striking against the center we have
bishop to e4 now attacking the knight
and the knight also can't move so rook
to c8 on pinning and defending with h3
and here maxine gives up the light
square bishop captures captures and
queen d7 adding another defender to the
knight here also connecting the rooks
with bishop to d3 and now comes c
captures on d4 uh sorry about that i
think meadow wants to come in
yep that was him
uh so uh c captures on d4 and now uh
grabbing finally the b5 pawn bishop
captures on b5 putting pressure on the
knight here uh d captures on c3 and now
queen captures on c3 so yes you are
putting the queen in front of the rook
but if the knight moves also bishop
captures and d7 is there so queen to d5
going after the a2 pawn and we have a
trade bishop captures queen captures and
now rook to a1 attacking the queen and
here maxine plays a most interesting
move uh he could move the queen of
course queen to e6 for example that's a
nice move but he actually plays knight
captures on e5 and um uh he offers his
queen for uh for uh magnus's queen
but uh you know at the end of the day he
just grabbed a pawn so uh he he will be
up a pawn and the thing is sorry there
are a couple of ways you could treat
this you could just trade on the spot
with queen captures on c8 which is
possible uh let's say uh queen captures
on a1 we're going to play queen back to
c2 and now let's say rook to a8 going
after the bishop we defend the bishop
and now e6 and the game continues maxine
being up upon so this is one possibility
uh but the magnus goes for the other one
after knight captures on e5 he just
trades rook captures on a2 maxim grabs
the queen on c3 and bishop to d2 and
okay maxime is up upon magnus has the
bishop pair so you should not uh be able
to to push this all the way but it's uh
uh you know it's still a game and it's a
classical one so rook back to c8 and now
bishop to b5 uh re-maneuvering the
bishop over to e2 rook to c5 attacks the
bishop bishop back to e2 and now knight
to c6 we have rook to c1 offering a rook
trade and now rook captures with bishop
captures and now rook to b8
uh finally developing that rook
bishop to e3 and now bishop to d4
offering a trade of bishops as well but
as magnus is down upon he's not
interested in giving up the bishop pair
so bishop h6 bishop g7 bishop back to e3
checking if maxine will repeat but
maksim doesn't repeat maksim wants to
play he plays h5
g3 we have pawn to e6 and now king the
g2 by magnus and now knight to b4
re-maneuvering the knight to d5 to put
pressure on the e3 square or the bishop
so rook to d2 uh we have knights to d5
and here magnus doesn't move the bishop
let's say you go bishop g5 then we
further attack her with f6 and so on he
just plays rook to d3 and now he gives
up the bishop pair he says all right you
you can have it but you're still not
winning this so knight captures rook
captures and bishop to d for now uh
harassing the rook rook to d3 now pawn
to e5 we have rook to d2 and king to g7
pawn to h4 and now king to h6 with f4
now of course you can't capture the uh
because the bishop would hang bishop to
e3 and now rook to d7 going after the f7
pawn but here maxime just plays e
captures on f4 and capturing an f7 would
be a deadly mistake here because if you
capture here uh rook to b2 uh beautiful
winning idea we just uh
attacked the bishop there's no really a
good way to defend it if king f3 we just
play f captures and g3 we even give up a
piece here so king captures an e3 now g2
how are you stopping the past pawn if
king f2 just rook captures here there's
no capturing the g2 pawn if king g1 we
just move the rook we give up the pawn
and once we capture this pawn we're up
two pawns of course this is now
completely winning for maxine so instead
of this after he captures uh on f4 we
have g captures on f4 and now pawn to f5
by maxine king to f3 and here we have
bishop uh
bishop back to c1 interestingly if you
threaten some nasty discoveries let's
say try something like rook to b3 uh
magnus can always go for this uh bishop
uh the g8 idea and try to deliver
checkmate here you're not going to be
able to do it but it's still a fun
attempt let's say rook b4 bishop to g8
now we play rook captures on f4 with
check give up the bishop on e3 and now
rook captures uh here but okay first we
deliver a check and here let's say we go
capture on h4 now the king has the g5
square he has the three three pawns for
the bishop and it's uh well
it's a draw but if anything black should
be better
uh so game instead after king f3 with
bishop back to c1 by maxine bishop the
c4 magnus now going for this very nice
idea if the rook ever moves from the
back rank rook the c8 attacks the bishop
and now bishop to f7 now you also have
to be careful uh so you don't uh blunder
the g6 pawn rook to c3 with check we
have king to g2 and now bishop captures
an f4 and here
what can magnus play well magnus plays
bishop to g8 he is now down two pawns
and he has to do something about this so
he plays king bishop to g8 goes after
this checkmate now pawn to g5 by maxine
and here magnus uh plays uh not h
captures if h captures king captures
this is an active king two two past
pawns of course black will win this
magnus instead plays bishop to e6 he
goes after this pawn uh and here uh
well it's uh it's a very tricky position
but it's a completely winning one for
maxime so feel free to pause the video
here
and try to find the move that wins the
game for maxine while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations but also this was a
warm up because the second positive
video moment will be even uh even
tougher
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is g captures on h4
this is not what maxine played he missed
this one uh point is that now if bishop
captures on f5 we have h3 with check
that's the
that's the whole point and now what do
you play uh there's really uh no no good
move you can play if you play bishop
captures on h3 then rook to g3 with
check and now you can't keep defending
the bishop if you go
king h2 you go under the mask of the
bishop then we just play rook to g7 open
up a discovery and pick up the rook on
d7
uh
not
not a lot of fun for example king to h3
okay yeah you can't really play that
because the bishop defends the rook but
you can play uh something like rook to
d3 with check and after king to g2 we're
gonna play rook to g3 again and after
king to h2 now we're gonna play this
bishop to b8 move that's uh
that's the way to do it and now there's
uh
there's no good move for uh for uh for
white because you can't move the king
you can't really move the bishop
anywhere
because if you move the bishop let's say
to f5 we just win the bishop we make a
discovery pick it up
so you have to move the rook and once
the rook moves anywhere
from the light to d7 square then we can
win it for example if rook d8 now rook j
to check and we pick up the rook so it's
a really really tricky line uh and of
course definitely uh
an easy one to miss so you're not going
to be able to play bishop captures on h3
you're gonna have to play something
let's say king f2 now comes h2 and now
after rook to d1 uh preventing this pawn
from being queen you're gonna play rook
to g3 and now this is the point rook h1
and now uh you are going to play rook to
g1 and there is no way at uh not to save
this because if rook captures uh we just
play bishop to e3 check and only after
the king captures we're going to pick up
the rook so here you would have this
position and you're not going to be able
to capture you're going to have to play
something like a bishop to e4 but now we
just play h4 h3 bring the king into the
game and slowly but surely you will you
will win this because white is without
any move so it's incredibly complicated
uh and not all that uh
difficult to imagine that you would miss
that this is winning uh because if you
can't calculate the exact uh perfect
line you will not play this so instead
of king to g6 by maxine but now magnus
just plays rook d5 now he will win the
f5 pawn g4 we have bishop captures on f5
king f6 and bishop to h7 now going after
the h5 pawn and now bishop to e5
blocking the attack this way bishop to
g6 now offering a trade of bishops
and here if you really wanted you could
just capture this and it's a draw but
maxim doesn't want to do this and it's
um
it's actually a beautiful drive if king
captures rook captures here and you play
rook to h3 you say okay i'm going to win
this pawn i'm going to be up two pawns
how is this a draw it's actually a very
very simple draw let's say rook a5 or
something a rook captures an h4 now how
do you okay let's say rook a6 check how
do you
make progress here the only way to
prevent the rook from checking you is to
go all the way zigzag your way through
checks and try and force the rook
somewhere else
but even if that happens let's say king
f5 you deliver checking here checking
here checking here
now you will not play rook to a4 with
check but rather you will play rook to
a3 and that's the whole point now you
don't have this rook to h3 move
and you don't have any other moves with
the rook you don't have a pawn move so
you can just move your king but that
will not help you um for example you you
can attack the uh rook here but we're
just gonna play rook to g3 and you can't
further advance the king you can go with
the king all the way to here but then
we're just gonna move the rook and you
can never bring your rook into the game
and you cannot do anything here even
though you're up to pawn so it's a very
very uh classy move by magnus this
bishop the g6 idea trying to get a draw
here uh but uh maxine uh sees right
through it he plays g3 uh we have rook
to a3 uh sorry uh we've rooked to a5 and
now comes rook to c4 putting pressure on
the pawn here rook to a6 with czech king
to g7 and finally bishop captures on g5
we have rook captures on h4 now maxime
does have a protected pass pawn but it's
very hard to push this with the black
king being so inactive rook to g6 with
czech king h7 and now rook the g5
attacking the bishop rook h2 check king
to f3 here king to g1 and king to f1 are
the only possible moves that don't lose
the game for white after king to f3 uh
magnus's position is again lost but it's
again incredibly hard to see it rook f2
check was played king g4 bishop to f4
attacking the rook and the rook to g6
and now again we have this incredibly
complicated position where there is a
winning idea but it's just uh
yeah okay
feel free to pause the video and try to
try to spot this one while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
well uh positional uh brilliancy and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is bishop the c7 uh
interestingly you could also play bishop
to e5 your position is still winning you
could also play bishop b8 your position
will still be winning uh but it's it's
basically a matter of uh just wasting
moves until you finally play bishop to
c7 because you will need the d8 square
to actually win this
but the real idea is that we want to
take away the f5 square from the white
king that's the whole point we want to
force the white king
either on h4 or on h3 uh the point is
and uh you will see why uh because maxim
missed this idea but after bishop the c7
how do you play this uh of course if you
go uh if you move the king somewhere
because now the f file is off limits we
just play rook to h2 with check and once
king g4 is played rook to h1 and now we
are covering the g1 square so now g2 g1
uh this is unstoppable it doesn't really
matter what you play uh
you could play anything let's say you
play king to f3 we just play rook
captures on h5 so you have to keep
defending the bishop if you play king to
g5 uh we simply play bishop to d8 with
check that's why the bishop on c7 was
crucial and after king g4 just g2 you
can't prevent rook to g1 it's uh just
unstoppable so uh another thing after
bishop the c7 okay you don't have to
play king to h4 you could play rook to
g5 just try and waste the move uh
doesn't really matter now we play rook
to f1 and again we control the queening
square and after let's say rook g6 you
try to waste a move g2 now comes king h3
and of course g1 queen we pick up the
uh queen and we have a completely
winning endgame so that's why here i'm
moving the bishop was uh uh winning
bishop to c7 the the actual winning move
uh but maxine played rook to f1 uh it
seems like it's the same and we want to
go into that line but he now gives
magnus one move that he wouldn't have in
that line and that is king to f5 the
only winning the only move that saves
the game for magnus he he of course
spots it and he hides the king on f5
there are there are no good discoveries
all of white's pieces are on light
squares so bishop the g5 check was
played here trying one last trick of
course if magnus captures then g2 is
winning now uh you can't just move the
king because if king h4 rook to h1 and
you force the king back to the g file
king g3 g1 check you have a queen why
doesn't of course completely winning so
king e4 was played now comes rook to f4
and king to d3 uh we have rook to f5 and
now king the e4 again not allowing maxim
to start pushing his pawn because we
would just gobble up the rook and after
this uh queen comes into the game we
gobble up the bishop as well and the
queen will not be able to win against uh
the the the rook and bishop so instead
we have rook therefore with chuck king
d3 and now bishop to h4
rook to e6 and now finally ponte g2 we
have rooked the g6 and now guarding the
queening square rook to f5 attacking the
bishop
and here you don't really have an option
of saving the bishop because here maksim
is preparing rook to g5 and then he will
just queen his spawn so you have to give
up the bishop rook captures on g2 and
now rook captures on h5 and of course
this is a known draw both magnus and
mbl are uh more than able to to to draw
this easily especially in the classical
game but of course it's uh polite to try
and see if your opponent is in a good
mood uh he might he might blunder the
game so bishop to f6 we have king to f4
bishop to g7 and now king to e4 you just
wait for black to try and force
something king to g8 he has to bring the
king into the game rook to g6 we have
king to f7 now comes rook to a6 cutting
off the black king from
going uh after the white king bishop to
f6 now comes rook to a8 uh rook to h for
check king to f5 rook to h5 check king
to e4 magnus shows that he knows he
knows his stuff uh rook the b5 now comes
a bishop uh king to f4 we have bishop to
e5 check king the e4 bishop to d6 and
now rook the h8 and he was in this
position on move 79 that magnus and
maxime agree to a draw as there is
nothing more to be done here so really
an incredible game uh they've played
many many games especially in this
groomfield defense that uh is so so
enjoyable to watch uh magnus uh defeated
him many times and now maxine finally
had his chance he had two two great
winning winning ideas but uh as you've
seen both of them are incredibly
complicated and uh
unfortunately for maxine he he misses
both of them but they are going into
armageddon and we are going to see what
happened there most likely in the next
video but also maybe
maybe not we'll see how it goes uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys enjoy
that we're gonna cover a few more games
before we check out the standings as a
lot has happened uh i would like to
thank charles huff nagarjuna pongotti
timo salon adrian martin nagorski and
benjamin bogwell for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes so
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day